este es el uniforme que se pone cada
mañana el de los conductores de taxi de
la capital india la rutina de rajesh
kumar desde hace cinco años
una jornada laboral de 12 horas que
empieza con una limpieza rápida de su
vehículo
para obtener una buena nota el vehículo
debe brillar a lo contrario los clientes
se quejaran ya que en mega de él y la
competencia es ruda la megalópolis
cuenta con unos 400.000 conductores de
vtc que usan plataformas digitales como
está titulado de sistemas registro
abandonó su antiguo empleo en el 2017
seducido por las promesas de esta
startup norteamericana de ganar más
dinero más rápidamente pero su sueño de
ser financieramente independiente se
volvió una pesadilla muy rápida
me siento engañado cuando llegué a über
nos prometían el oro y el muro que nos
remunerar ian con hasta 1.300 euros
mensuales
estoy lejos de eso
si logro ganar 400 euros es un milagro
ya que para seducir un mercado indio
gigantesco la plataforma digital que usa
les propuso a los clientes entre las
tarifas más bajas del mundo el precio
mínimo de una carrera en nueva delhi es
de un euro apenas de sus ingresos reyes
debe deducir los gastos que le
corresponden y reembolsar el préstamo
que sacó para comprar su vehículo sin
contar con la comisión que le retiene en
la aplicación hasta el 30% difícil para
este padre de dos hijos atender las
necesidades de su familia al final del
mes cada mañana debo tanquear el
vehículo y el litro de gpl está cada vez
más costo luego está el mantenimiento
del vehículo muy costoso igualmente en
seguida debo vivir con lo que me queda
para comprar los alimentos y pagar los
estudios de mis hijos un ejército de
precarios es lo que esconde el éxito de
la economía la tarea en la india uber
olaso matos with urban company el país
cuenta con 800 aplicaciones de esta
naturaleza en menos de 10 años estas
estructuras en su mayoría indias
popularizaron los servicios de entrega
transporte o cuidado a domicilio para
millones de indios plataformas son
vistas como la promesa para salir de la
pobreza y escapar del desempleo cuya
tasa de 8% en el 2021 nunca había estado
tan elevada desde hace 13 años tal es el
caso de subas 5 23 años se volvió
mensajero tras haber perdido su empleo
durante la pandemia
acepte el pedido cuento tan solo con 30
segundos desde el momento en el que
recibió la señal
tras haber aceptado la carrera suba en
cuenta con 40 minutos para entregar el
pedido empieza una carrera contra el
reloj en la polución el calor y los
trancones sin contar las calles
laberínticas de la capital india
al señor el llegado de frente de su
domicilio suban trabaja 12 horas al día
6 días de 7 por un salario de unas diez
mil rupias mensuales es decir 120 euros
se siente a merced de las plataformas de
los restaurantes y de los clientes para
ellos somos sus esclavos la política de
la plataforma es que el cliente siempre
esté satisfecho si no lo están nuestra
nota baja podemos recibir sanciones y
nuestro salario puede disminuir no les
importa saber que hay trancones que la
calle está mal que el plato no está bien
porque viajo en malas condiciones o fue
mal empacado si un cliente anula el
pedido porque está descontento se deduce
del monto de mi salario en la india la
economía a la tarea no es un fenómeno
nuevo el 80% de la economía del país es
informal y a decenas de millones de
indios les pagan al día según este
experto estas plataformas digitales
agravan esta situación en ausencia de
regulación los trabajadores no cuentan
con ningún estatus ni asalariados ni
independientes y no cuentan con
protección todas sus plataformas
digitales se aprovechan del desempleo en
todos los países donde se instala pero
en realidad en la india sólo refuerzan
la informalidad de la economía
la economía la tarea es un empleo
informal no hay ninguna protección
social para los trabajadores ningún
contrato ningún soporte de pago ninguna
seguridad de empleo ninguna garantía o
protección en caso de accidente laboral
denunciar estas condiciones laborales
trae consecuencias sin machín es
esteticista hace algunos meses proponían
sus servicios a través de una aplicación
de cuidados a domicilio hasta una nueva
alza de la comisión retenida por la
plataforma
yo soy la de verde tratan de sacarme de
la manifestación
durante semanas protesto con otras
trabajadoras frente a la sede de la
compañía el resultado fue que así me fue
denunciado ante la justicia acusada de
manifestar ilegalmente
y los representantes de la compañía
amenazaron a los manifestantes la
policía ejerció igualmente presión sobre
ellas algunas fueron convocadas a la
comisaría el precio que pague es que me
sacaron de la plataforma como
chasqueando de louis desempleada tras
haber trabajado durante cuatro años sin
nosotros jamás se habrían vuelto esta
gran empresa trabajamos tanto y después
de todo esto así es como nos agradecen
recientemente la corte suprema india le
solicitó al gobierno que pusiera en
marcha un sistema de protección social
para los trabajadores de las plataformas
digitales la que según un estudio
norteamericano en la geek economy podría
generar hasta 90 millones de nuevos
empleos a largo plazo en la india